- Okay, wait, I don't
wanna not talk about this,
'cause you've also got a
crime movie with Brad Pitt.
- Yeah.
(crowd cheers)
- So, it's out this summer?
- Yeah.
- So, what's that about?
- You know, I've always had a dream
of being in an action movie
where you get like all the explosions
and the slow motion walk,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And I got to do it and I
got to do it with Brad Pitt.
And I was like, "I know you lying."
(both laugh)
Yeah and I got to be blonde.
I was like, "Yes, I get to be blonde,
I always wanna try it." (crowd laughs)
- So, you're still rebelling?
- I'm still rebelling.
(all laughing)
That is literally kinda what
my hair looked like in college.
And I was like, "Oh, that's
a little too close to home."
(crowd laughing)
But yeah, it's a great, great
film called "Bullet Train,"
directed by David Leitch,
who did "Atomic Blonde" and "Deadpool".
And we did this in the
middle of the quarantine,
so like in October-
- But you worked all in
quarantine, that's cool.
- I am insane, I told you I was a rebel.
- I worked too,
I never stopped here.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- I don't know how-
- It was a nice distraction.
- I feel like I need
to be interviewing you,
so you can have a break.
(Kelly laughs)
- Trust me, I'm tired,
I'm gonna have a weekend.
- You wanna switch?
No don't switch.
- It's kinda nice though,
because I don't feel like I
was affected during quarantine
like everybody else was in that sense.
- So, yeah, 'cause you were still
doing something.
- Because I had
to still keep going, so
there was no time to process.
- It was the same with "Bullet Train."
We filmed on Sony, they built a train.
They built cars of the train.
There was a huge screen
with moving pictures going.
I felt like it was very classic Hollywood,
like back in the twenties
when there's 30 people
moving a set and turning this
and you had to get back
to the bare minimum.
- That's cool.
- But yeah, it's a huge action movie.
The cast is in insane and
I got to fight Brad Pitt.
- Yeah.
- Like I get
to kick Brad Pitt's ass (crowd laughs)
and it was kinda great
because this man was the
happiest he had ever been.
And also-
- Oh that's cool.
- We have a lot of fights together
and there's one particular
time that we're fighting
and I got him in a choke hold
and they would yell, "Cut,"
and he would just lay my arms.
And I was like, "Oh."
(crowd laughs)
I was like, "How is it possible
that I feel safer with
you lying in my arms?"
And it's like, 'cause it's Brad Pitt.